louis jackson sat with all his fellow
students in the dingy underground
lecture hall listening to a rickety old
professor with a voice like chloroform
rattling off dry facts about economics
above him a projector older than any of
the students in the room covered the
wall in a poorly designed powerpoint
presentation limping from slide to slide
it was 9 am on a thoroughly unremarkable
monday half the class was hung over the
other was just terminally bored lewis
hoped none of this would come up on the
final because this morning he had no
intention of listening instead he was
typing out a message under the desk with
a big stupid grin on his face professor
harbison is going off about the free
market again save me send the messages
recipient jenny park started typing
lewis's crush on jenny was the college's
worst kept secret ever since they met
during o week he'd been infatuated with
her they shared a few classes but little
by little they started hanging out more
in their free time study sessions
grabbing lunch together going to the
movies they'd become fast friends but
lewis was hoping they could be something
more and he hoped deep down jenny was
thinking the same thing he received a
text we can hang out in the quad after
if it makes him easier to endure we'll
grab burgers my treat with a winking
emoji lewis felt like a dork to admit it
even to himself but this message made
his heart race they were doing winking
emojis now maybe today wouldn't be such
a drag after all any day that he got to
hang out with jenny couldn't be all that
bad all this news was so exciting to him
he didn't notice that something strange
was sweeping over the lecture hall while
the professor drowned on even the most
studious members of the class were
suddenly checking their phones faces a
light with expressions of confusion then
concern then worry something was
happening something big professor
harbison fell silent as a new sound rose
to prominence muffled at first but
getting rapidly louder just outside the
lecture hall it was screaming terrible
screams of fear and pain people started
to rise out of their seats what was
going on out there nobody had heard
gunshots or an explosion the ground
wasn't rumbling under their feet and if
a hurricane or tornado was tearing its
way across the campus they would have
heard it suddenly the main doors to the
lecture hall burst open and a terrified
student rushed through lewis recognized
him it was tommy landsdale a history
major that lewis had hung out with a few
times at campus parties he was the chill
guy the kind of person who took
everything on the chin and let life's
troubles just roll off his back that's
why it was so strange to see his whole
body shaking and his face a red mess of
tears
he can't go out there he screamed
there's something wrong with the light
concern was starting to give way to
panic tommy turned and shoved the bolt
into place on the door eliminating the
potential exit the only other way out
was a fire escape down by the stage his
heavy breathing and choked sobs weren't
doing much to calm anyone down lewis
checked his phone again jenny was still
typing tommy kept repeating something's
wrong with the light something's wrong
with the light something's wrong with
the light the other students were
starting to approach him all with a
sense of guarded caution given they
still didn't understand the situation
well enough to know for sure that tommy
wasn't the dangerous one here college
could be an extremely stressful place it
definitely wasn't unheard of for people
to snap under the pressure and do
something they wouldn't normally do
what what's going on man lewis said
walking briskly up to tommy worried
about jenny's safety if something really
was happening out there tommy raised
both hands in a gesture that seemed
halfway between pleading and a threat
shaking his head frantically stay back
dude
you don't want to go out there something
terrible is happening professor harbison
approached adjusting his glasses and
sneering he didn't take kindly to
someone interrupting his lecture with
these ridiculous theatrics an institute
of learning was no place for this kind
of troublemaker i demand you leave this
instant young man harbison said if you
don't stop this foolish behavior i'll
have you written up tommy didn't budge
he just shook his head emphatically i'm
not going anywhere he said if you go out
there you're gonna die i'm not letting
anyone leave this damn building before
anyone could protest this unwilling
confinement a terrible sound started to
come from outside not screaming this
time just a voice a warped pained voice
that seemed almost to droop as it spoke
like a voice recorded on an old
reel-to-reel tape recorder that's
starting to degrade
me
it's slurred please
let me in
i
feel so sick
there was a terrible slopping noise like
a thick viscous liquid sluicing closer
tommy looked down and screamed
flesh-colored slime was slithering in
underneath the door and dripping over
the top step of the gangway tommy
stepped back along with everyone else it
looked revolting and smelled even worse
like a mixture of rotten meat and
burning hair that terrible drooping
voice was still somehow emanating from
the
slime please
please help me
something
wrong
naturally the other students began to
scream and run whatever that monster was
they needed to get away from it quickly
only lewis seemed to be rooted in place
the terror and impossibility of it all
just paralyzing him he could only watch
as the flesh-colored blob creature
seeped in under the door everything else
including professor harbison who was
moving faster than he had in years made
a mad dash for the fire exit down by the
stage tommy screamed for them to stay
inside but it was already too late
people panicked and piled on top of each
other to get out but the second they did
the worst of the screaming started the
most awful agonized whales you've ever
heard that tapered off in that same
drooping gurgle as the blob slithered in
underneath the door it was lewis's
natural instinct to run down and help
somehow but instead he felt tommy's
white knuckle grip on his shoulder
i'm sorry
tommy said through the sobs
it's too late for them there's nothing
you can do man we just need to stay
inside at that moment lewis received a
text message from jenny it read louis if
you're still okay you need to read this
and you need to believe me something
terrible has happened so many people are
dead or at least i think they're dead a
lot of them are still screaming i think
it has something to do with the sun stay
out of the light i'm in administration
building c i'm safe for now but i'm
hiding don't come looking for me until
nightfall please let me know if you're
okay you can't trust the sun lewis felt
a wave of relief and terror wash over
him jenny was okay and that was great
news but it seemed like this nightmare
whatever the hell it was was affecting
everyone out there it was a force
melting people down and turning them
into monsters the screams from outside
the door were getting worse all those
people who had been well people so
recently were something entirely
different now and they were in terrible
terrible pain lewis and tommy ran down
to the fire escape next to the stage and
forced it shut trying not to look at the
tide of liquid flesh that was rolling in
the apparently hostile sun outside they
were lost now tommy and lewis didn't
want them coming back in lewis breathed
a rattling sigh and hammered out a reply
to jenny i'm safe in a lecture hall with
tommy lansdale we'll come to you as soon
as we can don't worry it's all going to
be okay lewis shoved his phone back into
his pocket now isn't the time to keep
checking he asked tommy what he knew how
he had survived whatever all this was
having some kind of knowledge about what
they were dealing with might have given
them a better chance of surviving tommy
had just finished up a seminar in a
nearby classroom and was headed over to
the canteen to grab a reuben while
preparing for his next class he was
lucky enough to be under a covered
walkway bathed in the early morning
shade when something about the sun
changed it was hard to even describe a
certain shift in the quality of the
light a kind of
shimmer almost it didn't affect him but
the people in the courtyard a few feet
away he was shuttering as he told the
next part of the story he swallowed hard
over a lump in his throat staring off
into the distance with a haunted look as
the memories played over his mind tommy
described the people in the courtyard
the ones out of the shade who were first
exposed they just started screaming and
falling apart losing form
melting becoming awful piles of
shapeless slop on the ground it was
instantaneous and all it seemed to take
was a fraction of a second of sun
exposure for the whole process to take
effect nothing was worth the risk of
exposure to something like that nothing
but lewis disagreed there was one thing
worth risking his life or the integrity
of his body for
jenny they had to get to administration
building c as quickly as possible and
not just because of the new threat
raging outside but because building c
already had a certain
reputation rumor had it that a number of
people had gone missing in that building
back in the 1970s
since then people had experienced
strange inexplicable things odd chills
strange noises creeping feelings of doom
in certain areas in short it was the
last place lewis wanted jenny to be
trapped but neither he nor tommy could
help until night fell seeing as they
wouldn't be great rescuers in a
semi-liquid state they waited for 10
torturous hours in that lecture hall as
day turned to night outside in that time
they heard so many terrible bubbling
screams out there pain trying to escape
a slimy prison it was enough to drive
you mad with fear both checked the news
and their twitter feeds on their phones
hoping to find out if there was any more
information on what was happening out
there it seemed the worst had come to
pass this insane phenomenon was
unfolding everywhere people across the
world were suffering under the
transforming rays of the terrible new
sun some group called the scp foundation
was releasing information about it
telling people to come towards their
buildings at night for safety lewis
committed this fact to memory when
they'd collected jenny they'd head
straight to one of these buildings
hopefully someone out there could tell
them what the hell was going on here
someone out there had to have answers
about all of this when it got dark
outside lewis felt his phone buzz in his
pocket as he received another text from
jenny this time it was lewis i'm scared
please come quickly i'm downstairs and
with that lewis knew it was time to
leave he and tommy steeled themselves
and when they were sure it was dark out
they ventured forth from the lecture
hall and on to the quad there they saw
the aftermath of the horrors that the
sun had wrought the grass was covered in
more huge flesh-colored blobs slithering
across the grass like mutant slugs just
the side of them made lewis and tommy
feel nauseous but they didn't have time
to stop and take a breather if jenny was
in trouble they needed to get to
building c fast it looked even more
frightening at night it occurred to both
lewis and tommy at that moment that
neither of them had ever actually been
inside this building before and what
seemed like the end of the world was
certainly an interesting time to start
lewis and tommy entered the building and
turned on the lights in the lobby they
heard a voice at first oddly toneless
and robotic but soon realized it was a
video playing on loop on the computer at
the unmanned reception desk it was
another message from the scp foundation
this is a public service announcement
from the scp foundation we are
commandeering all broadcast channels and
frequencies to deliver a vital message
avoid sunlight at all costs cover your
bodies thoroughly and follow the
instructions on the screen to reach the
nearest operational scp foundation
containment site neither like the sound
of the phrase containment site but
they'd worry about the semantics later
jenny had said she'd been hiding
downstairs and there was no sign of her
here on the first floor so it stood to
reason she was on some kind of basement
level strange it seemed like all the
doors here led up except one a door that
looked like until very recently it had
been bolted to the wall well
lewis said trying to mask his fear i
guess it's now or never tommy opened his
mouth to answer but before a single word
could pass his lips a huge fleshy
tendril shot through the front door of
the building and wrapped around his
throat he managed only a choked gasp as
it dragged him back towards the door on
the other side of the threshold a
mountain of flesh eagerly waited a
gibbering nightmare of half-formed faces
screamed and wailed in the terrible
fleshy form it happened so quickly that
lewis couldn't even hope to save him he
was gone subsumed by the blob his face
disappearing into the flesh before lewis
could even scream but there was no time
to stop and process the shock another
several tendrils were already reaching
for him he could practically see it
happening in slow motion pulsing
grasping for him perhaps it was only his
will to see jenny again that gave him
the strength to do so but he dodged the
tendrils by a fraction of an inch and
dove towards the door the same door he
assumed jenny had escaped in two hours
earlier he threw open the door and
disappeared behind it slamming it in
place and holding it fast he could feel
the tendrils smashing up against it
hammering away lewis heard all those
terrible deranged voices screaming for
him on the other side he was holding it
for a solid 10 minutes before the
creature finally gave up and slithered
away the second the silence fell louis's
phone buzzed in his pocket again he
fished it out and saw another message
from jenny it read please come afraid so
dark here so dark here so dark here so
dark here and it was at that moment that
lewis began to take in his new
surroundings he was standing in a
stairwell one that seemed much older and
more dilapidated than even the rest of
the building but most notable of all was
the fact that he had never ever seen a
place so dark impossibly dark not dark
is in the absence of light but dark as
in an almost physical presence choking
out the light even with his phone on
full power the light didn't penetrate
much of the black was jenny all the way
down here lewis was afraid he could only
imagine how jenny was feeling down there
in the depths he took a deep breath and
started descending down into the
darkness using his phone camera to light
with little of the way was possible the
deeper he got the more he started to
feel a strange intangible dread
beginning to creep in like an invisible
hand compressing his chest as he got
deeper he noticed a sound quiet weeping
an unmistakably female voice
somewhere down below it sounded too
young to be jenny but then again lewis
had never actually heard her cry before
whatever the case he needed to get down
there and remedy the situation he forged
on further and further into the dark
even as his terrible sense of dread
increased he couldn't help but notice
that no matter how far down he went it
always sounded like the crying was the
same distance away it unnerved him but
jenny had to be down there she had to be
and even if he gave up on her it's not
like he could just go back up and leave
there were monsters out there like the
monster that had gotten tommy even down
here in the darkness he was safer than
up there or at least
that's what he thought he felt something
strange under his foot and looked down
it was an old piece of torn up orange
fabric with d 9884 written on it the
phone buzzed again a new message from
jenny this time it read i can see you
can you see me lewis looked around he
couldn't see anything he tried
desperately calling jenny again he
yelled her name until his voice went
hoarse no reply just that same soft
weeping so far below maybe she was on
the flight below him she must have been
close he doubled his speed vaulting down
the stairs to the next level when he
noticed something on the ground a
smartphone one that over so many study
dates lunches and outings to the movies
he learned to recognize it was jenny's
he picked it up studying it only to see
that it was dead the screen cracked in
the battery lifeless his own phone gave
another buzz a text from jenny it read
look down and against all rational
thought that's exactly what he did there
was something at the bottom of the
stairs a strange pale face somehow
illuminated in the darkness at first he
thought it could have been her and ran
towards it by the time he realized he
was wrong and he was staring into the
blank eyes of a face without a mouth
inches from his own face
it was already too late lewis let out a
scream there was nobody there to hear
him but on the bright side at least he
never would see that sunlight again now
go check out the secret at the bottom of
scp-087 explained and scp-087 trapped in
the stairwell for more tales of the
terrible things that happen when you
enter a certain anomalous stairwell